what is your strategy
so my strategy to big brother canada is
very simple i'm just going to treat all
the house guests like my cats i'm going
to give them pets i'm going to give them
scratches and i'm just going to treat
them well and feed them great
perfect uh what kind of personality will
you laugh with the most in the house
i will clash with somebody who is fake i
can't stand people who can't be honest
i'm like always been this quirky
individual and this is just who i am so
i'm like if i can see through you i i'm
not i'm not going to be with you
perfect uh
uh i'm for sure going to have a makeout
mans maybe like a flirtmance but i'm a
virgo i don't need a relationship
awesome uh and why is canada gonna work
for you canada better root for me look
at me i am i am who am i i am i'm jay
i i'm fun i'm loving i'm here to bring
the party i'm here to have some fun i'm
here to talk about the hard things as
well and i just want to make sure that
we change canada for the better every
moment that we can
you